So welcome back.
This is the final video in our exercise.
And for this, what we're going to be doing is we're going
to be doing an example of exposing some parameters so
that you can control the PCG volume from within the
editor. And here we are in the editor.
We've got our fabulous world with raw flowers.
What we're going to do is I'm going to add in a variable
that's going to control the amount of flowers that we have
on this ground.
So if I open back up my PCG graph, you can see that this
is where we would want to edit the flowers.
Now in the bottom left-hand corner here, I'm going to
come onto graph parameters.
I'm going to add a new property.
And as you can see, we can change the property type and do
a number of different things.
But I'm happy with it being a float.
And I'm going to rename this and I'm going to call this
flower amount.
Now for zero, we're going to have zero flowers.
And for one, we're going to have the maximum amount
of flowers that you can add.
So I will grab this, drag this in and drop this in.
And so this works just like getting a variable
inside of a blueprint.
We're just getting this amount and we're going to use that
as an input for the density filter.
Now if I do a drop down on the density filter, you can
see that we now have a lot of values that we can input too.
And what we care about is the lower bounds.
However, we need to invert this value.
So I'm going to drag off and I'm going to search for
one minus on the attribute maths operation.
Select one minus.
And so that means when it's one, we're going to be returning
zero.
When it's zero, we're going to be returning one,
0.5, 0.5.
It allows us to invert this value.
I'm going to plug this into the lower bounds.
Now if I save, it's got a default of one.
We've come back into the world.
We've got a default of zero, I think.
So first thing is you'll see all of our flowers have disappeared.
If I select our PCG volume, you'll see down here
we have the option to change some of the parameters.
So at the moment, this is set to zero.
If I was to change that to one, you'd see that we have
just flowers everywhere.
It's just a field of flowers at that point.
However, we can select a value somewhere in between.
So let me scale this up and actually drag it up and down.
So it's a bit hard because it's such a small value.
So let's try 0.7.
It's a lot of flowers.
That's 0.5.
Still a lot of flowers.
0.3.
So it's less flowers.
But it effectively gives us the ability to control the flowers.
We could go more advanced on this.
We could try and remap the value and do a whole lot of other software.
But you get the idea.
At this point, we are just going into the PCG graph.
We're creating a parameter and we can use them as inputs
to any of the specific nodes.
And we would be able to change how the different,
how the PCG functions based on the values that we put into it in the instance.
OK, and that brings us to the end of our exercise.
Next up, we're just going to be looking at a couple of different examples
so we can get an idea of what the PCG is capable of.